premier tu futuro sólo 4 segundos la
productora de televisión marina sanz y
cova aparece detrás de la presentadora
del medio estatal ruso canal 1 para
hablar en contra de la invasión a
ucrania antes de que el noticiero fuese
interrumpido de manera abrupta
anticipando su detención por la policía
grabó un vídeo antes para asegurarse de
que su mensaje llegue al público ruso
esto es lo que está sucediendo ahora en
ucrania es un crimen la responsabilidad
de esa agresión recae en la conciencia
de un solo hombre y ese hombre es
vladimir putin desde el comienzo de la
invasión rusa y ucrania el kremlin ha
censurado la información sobre el
conflicto las palabras invasión o guerra
son prohibidas voy a protestar por la
guerra también puede conducir a la
cárcel la policía arrestó a más de 4000
personas que participaron de
manifestaciones contra la guerra en toda
rusia solamente el 13 de marzo
este hombre que levantó una hoja de
papel en blanco fue detenido le
indicaron que incluso los cierres eran
ilegales el kremlin ha bloqueado redes
sociales como 'facebook' y 'twitter' y
muchos no saben lo que está pasando en
ucrania es por eso que marina oceánico
va sintió que era importante hablar de
manera pública
solo nosotros el pueblo ruso inteligente
y pensante tenemos el poder para detener
esta locura ve y protesta no temas no
pueden meternos a todos en la cárcel un
llamado a la acción que tiene su precio
enfrentar hasta cinco años de prisión